hi i'm matt henderson and i like making
mathematical animations
and recently i got a bit into making
animations that demonstrate chaos theory
so today i wanted to show a few chaos
theory animations
this one is bouncing balls and it's a
very simple system that
demonstrates chaos theory so we have is
actually two
balls that you'll start to see it's two
balls once they pass diverge
after just a few bounces they're going
on totally different
chaotic paths at the beginning we've got
they're on they're almost on the same
path
almost they start off um right next to
each other
and their initial positions are only or
equal up to the fourth decimal place and
the point is like one of the hallmarks
of
chaos is that there's this high
sensitivity to initial conditions where
you know even if it's four decimal
places off the the
difference between the two is
exponential over time until they are
just
on totally different paths as it seems
this one is the keyboards really yeah
when i posted this i kind of posed a
question you know isn't it surprising
that such a simple system is chaotic and
of course the answer is no because
simple and chaotic aren't
the opposites of each other when i think
of
chaos maybe i think of the weather you
know the butterfly effect
and that is a massively complex system
and that exhibits chaos
but it's not because it's complex that
it exhibits chaos is some more
fundamental thing about the
you know the non-linearity of the
differential equations or something like
that
this is in mathematica again it's
actually quite
simple piece of code that is basically
solving
the differential equation you've got
four
equations i could write them down as
well the way it's written in the code
is like this so y dash dash of t
equals minus g so
the second derivative of the y position
is a function of t and that is minus g
which is the
gravitational constant that's pretty
obvious right like the
how much something is accelerating down
is just due to gravity
so you're using the proper earth's
gravity as your number there in the in
the animation
yeah but i mean it doesn't really matter
because there's no
scale keys it's just abstract circle and
space but i could
it happens to be like one meter wide
i think or the radius would be one meter
but you know cool i just have i did put
in 9.81
as that number and then we have a
similar one for x
this is to say that there's no
acceleration
left and right these ones are just the
initial conditions here these last four
here
so we'll have we basically have the x
and y
start off at x 0
and y 0 which we will plug in one ball
will have
a slightly different initial x0 than the
other ball does
and then the other one is just to say
that they start off
stationary so this is you know the
derivatives
start off at 0 zero the speed
in the x direction is zero speed in the
y direction is zero at the beginning
so there's this there's this um sneaky
bit in here
so this is saying when it happens that x
squared plus y squared equals one
which is the equation of the circle then
i'm going to
change the derivative of x and y into
the reflected values essentially now
mathematica is going to take this
set of equations it's going to look out
for that crossing point on the circle
and reflect the speeds so i'm plugging
in
x and y so this is the first ball x is
.001
just off the center and y is 0.5
and then for the second ball it's .0012
so it differs in the fourth decimal
place that's a
horizontal difference so the x's are
left and right
so if you run this code now what it's
done is it's computed
what these x and y positions are
so if i if if i want to just sort of
visualize those
that's what one of the balls paths looks
like and if i want to
plot the other one you know change this
to x f2
yft so this is the whole solution
so before you ever saw the animation you
saw this
yeah that's right um yeah that's a
spoiler
yeah i i mean before i saw this i saw a
whole bunch of like
red boxes saying you got your code wrong
um
and maybe i saw a few where it didn't
detect the circle properly or the
reflection was wrong
[Music]
this one is another simple yet chaotic
system this one is highlighting the
difference between
something that isn't chaotic and then
just a subtle change
that suddenly makes it chaotic so here
we have two
pool tables one with perfectly straight
edges and one that has
walls are slightly curved now
the balls all start moving off um
together in a group and the balls aren't
going to
interfere with each other they're just
separate trajectories models completely
independently so they're kind of the
balls are transparent to each other yeah
that's right obviously when they hit the
wall
they're going to reflect pictures look
pretty similar actually these are nice
slightly more spread out because of the
sort of like a mirror a bendy mirror or
like a lens
kind of effect there are we calling that
concave or convex
yeah it should be convex to the table
but concave to the outside of the table
yeah
yeah i guess everything that's convex is
also concave depends on your perspective
and they bounce up here and now you can
really see that
things have first of all they're balls
in a different part of the table
while these are still in a circular
shape that they started off in
these have nice spread out into more of
an elliptical shape
just as with the other bouncing balls oh
soon they're just all spread out and
chaotic and you know
if i if you were to see this picture
without the lines
and you were to say well where did they
start off
you wouldn't even have a clue right and
actually
in in a sense it's a fundamental
fact of the mathematics that you would
you couldn't have a clue because you
you wouldn't be able to measure with
enough precision and if you let the time
go on for long enough
and the other ones will stay in that
circle forever yeah this is a you know
this is obviously a mathematical
idealized tool table what i wanted to
get at was
what is the simplest change to a system
that could
result in chaos you know what's
happening is that
these bounces are more complex than
these bounces which are
very linear these ones are non-linear
and they
they start spreading things out and
there's a whole field of
studying these they're called billiards
problems
and you've got different types of
failures different
shapes it's kind of interesting in a
circle for example
things are not chaotic and they kind of
keep contracting in and out and bouncing
around the circle
[Music]
the other you if you put like a square
in the middle of the circle it
interferes with it and all of a sudden
that
is chaotic
[Music]
i wonder how long you would have to wait
for that to return to a circle just by
pure chance
there's a theorem that said that if you
wait long enough that would happen
yeah and obviously there's another point
which is the
what would happen in a real work world
like people when you're playing um
pool you're going to be in a world more
like this than
than this there's you're not going to
have perfectly straight edges
so if you're looking at making a shot
you want to minimize the number of
bounces that have to go
exactly to your plan because after you
know one
two three four five bounces
things are way off trajectory from the
ideal world
[Music]
this is a water wheel
that is a model for the lorenz attractor
which you might have seen before is this
kind of like butterfly shaped
3d thing that typifies a lot of chaotic
systems
what we've got is a water wheel with
lots of
these buckets that can collect water we
have water flowing in from the top
it's not stable so that when if you
start filling up the top
uh bucket then it will start spinning in
whatever direction is
off by so here we start filling and it
starts to spin to the left
so another aspect of this wheel is that
the buckets are slowly leaking water
which i haven't um animated but
oh you could imagine it as the watch is
evaporating or just disappearing over
time and there's also a little bit of
friction to the wheel
these add up to giving a chaotic system
in that the movement of this dot here
which is the center of mass of the wheel
that movement
is chaotic center of mass that's the
center of the mass of the wheel okay
yeah that's right and it i mentioned
it's a
it's related to the lorenz system
uh the lorenz system has this classic
kind of 3d butterfly
wing shape to it and this is this is
kind of visible in the trace that the
center of mass gives uh
yeah it's kind of a coincidence was a
total coincidence that the butterfly
effect
is some aspect of chaos theory and that
there's this butterfly wing
shaped um attractor that you get in a
bunch of chaotic systems like this
but you know it's kind of a nice title
as to say like visualizing the butterfly
effect and
i'm not sure if you really believe this
looks that much like a butterfly
tractor is a space a subspace inside the
3d space that things
end up converging onto for in this case
you could start the
wheel with any kind of initial motion or
you could fill up the water
anywhere you wanted but if you let it
evolve over time under its own laws of
physics the point
will soon get onto this consistent kind
of butterfly wing shape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you